来这个蓝色的
蓝色的一个鱼尾
蓝色的一条鱼尾
刚刚那个是一个黄绿色的吧
来腰尾
66到80
臀尾96
全场83
这个29
扣0
29块
来这一款
后面有拉链
有分离扣
这一条
这个属于那个雪纺呢
然后是一个霉红色的一个小半圈
看看下半
超级大
下半超级大
这一款
来腰尾
腰尾72
・・
这个是2块
你看
全场50
这个9块
扣个5
9块扣5
扣5
9块
扣个5
来
灰色
这个有一个那个那个bling bling的金丝线里面
这一条来腰围六十四八十六十四八十群长四十七九块扣六九块九块扣六扣六五块减六个六
来来来来姐妹妹
陪留的人呢
这一会儿都吃饭去了吗
是不是都吃饭去了呀
都没人呢
这个是
这个牌
灰色
灰色灰色是一个短袖
来胸围
胸围
134到140
134 140
一长一长七十一
这个十九给你们大满了
这个这个小苹果和妹猪妈
在群里赛图的一块
这个是一个灰色
十九十九
扣一个
一扣一
十九扣个一
十九扣一
这张账的挑 Different
从始终的是你
以后给我下一张
马卡龙吗
你现在是在哪里
那边
啊
这张做 tossed
这个 Olio
人呢
来这个短袖
这一款卫领
腰上是松紧的
来这个胸围
胸围90 96
90 96的胸围
来这个长度
长度95
这个9块
9块扣个5
9块9块扣5扣5
这个是地球音乐家的一个圈
9块扣个5
这俩可以搭一套
还有一个工装裤呢
大裤腿的
然后裤腿上是有一个
环扣露腿的
全松紧
腰围62
62 94
腿围104 108
当长38
裤长100
这个29给你们
这个地方有一点粗杀线的
29 29扣1扣1
29块扣个1扣个1扣个1
这个地方有一条粗杀线
不明显有一丢丢
29块和刚刚那个大
大短袖一样的
可以搭一套
我感觉
,
这个是
对对领一个打点
人棉人棉的领款
来胸围
胸围是94的116
94 116
来这个长度55
这个9块扣5扣5
9块9块扣个5
抱人的这款打底
对对领的人棉呢
9块扣5
来这个这个是个黑色
采了一个白色明线这一件
然后这个标的是个啥
标的是L尺码一个距离的
L尺码一个距离的
来胸围
胸围130 136
130 136的胸围
来这个一长
一长75
这个1919扣8
19块扣8扣8
19扣个8扣个8
1919扣8扣8
来这一个
这个是一个这样的一个小上衣
灰色
上面拼接一个蕾丝的
上面拼接一个蕾丝
蕾丝微领微领
来胸围
胸围是98114
来这个长度
长度61
这个后面有裤子
少了一个裤眼
你们回去自己弄一个小松拧
或者一个小布头
给它整一个小
那个小那个叫啥
裤眼就行了
9块9块
扣1扣1
9块扣1
面料很好
修口的话也是有睫毛蕾丝的
这个上面拼接蕾丝
9块9块
扣1扣1
来这一块
这个是
这个刚过了
这个男女同款的这一款
那个迪士尼的联名款
9块扣8
9块扣个8
这个刚过了一件
我就不量了
没有要扣号的
我再量
来这一款
这个是灰色加黑色的衬衣
这个是灰色加黑色的一个衬衣
胸围120124
长度71
来这个9块
9块扣个1
9块9块
扣1扣1
不是吗
来咯是吧
9块
沙棉高货
这个牌
这个牌M码高货
沙棉这一款是
来胸围
胸围96 98
96 98
长度75
这个后面有点脏
原价是59的
这里有一点脏了
看到没
脏了一块
这个咱们有腰的
不介意的抠
来 29
29 抠3
29块
抠3 抠3
29 抠个3
29块
抠3 抠3
这一块卡其色
卡其色一个威灵
腰上是拼接的
威灵
来
胸围
胸围96 100
96 100的胸围
来长度
长度78
这个咱们有腰的扣
来这个有腰的19
抠1
19 抠个1
节油加到这个上
看洗表有不看
这个牌S码
距职65
年35的
这个牌
来这个19
19 抠8
19块
抠8 抠8
来这一块
这个是属于一个叫什么
这叫什么 尼龙100的
我给你挤一下
来来来来
这个牌这个牌子的
来这个胸围
胸围的话是126 134
长度78
来这个19扣5
19扣个5扣个5
19扣个5
来这个雪纺的
袖拱黑了一个点
袖 哇两个呢
我天呐
两个大黑点
嗯
这个这个前面是有一个飘带雪纺雪纺的
这个是
来
胸围
胸围98 102
98 102
长度60 9块
9块9块扣6扣6
9块钱扣6扣6
雪纺呢就是袖子上有两个大黑点
有B Apart
inet
我皮疙瘩
有view
好
我先盖到这里
如果你觉得我给你一 graduating
的
而且
我们拿到这个
脸
的
项链
额
生
呀
신기
鱼
菌
Tory
胖
导
我
逆 Đ понятно
这个是一个雪纺 威灵威灵的这一件
来 胸围
胸围102110 长度60
这个9块 扣8
然后这个袖子上是有蝴蝶结的
这个吊牌架是7000多的一个吊牌架
原来卖29的 现在没有多少了
跟你们放福利的 9块扣1
来 这个上面少了一个小扣子
这一块 看没 黑色 这种滑纹的
来 胸围
胸围94100 94到100
来 长度83
这个9块 扣个3
9块9块 扣3
9块扣个3
来 这个后面有一个小纽扣
这一款是人眠辉煌的一个中长款的一个上衣
人呢 人呢 咋都没人说话了
来
胸围
长度78
来这个9块 扣个8
9块扣8
两边开叉
两边小开叉的这个是
人眠 人眠辉煌的这个上衣
可以当裙子也可以
7块钱 9块钱
人呢 人呢
姐妹们
来这个小短款的一个黑色
小上衣黑色黑色
来胸围
胸围的话是96到100
96 100的胸围
来这个长度